previously during the investigation yep
this smart you can't also put the two
there that's not that's not oh you still
got the smile Wow I love him only an
amateur would call a clock the the speed
at which he's running versus the
animation it doesn't it doesn't line up
I don't know I don't know what's
happening anymore cuz what I think
bullying I think Cajun cuisine I've seen
weirder mash up some of yours
alright Bend we are back with more
Deadly Premonition - yeah I still can't
believe this game exists same like I
said I said it's a blessing in disguise
it's not just a subtitle but a way that
I feel and I gotta say I feel like it's
really lived up to just being absolutely
batshit oh there he is ass David what is
with that accent my dude oh there it is
yes we are oh did look at the bathroom
on the first floor stronger water
pressure is feared yet he was talking
about the water pressure oh wow he's
living up to all of your fantasy here
this is this is the perfect hotel for
York okay you love to see it we go check
in a flipping chicken on the ice wanna I
want to interact with everything because
I'm pretty sure there's a chance for a
movie reference anywhere
run over quickly change and then I'm
still saying I think this is gonna be a
grim fandago type of reveal with the
ticket guys at the at the cat track they
actually are different people and we're
only gonna figure out like okay he's
wearing like a wife beater with just a
tie a bow tie
that's the the game industry standard
dude when you're going to a an event
you want to dress up but not dress up
game industry casual Isis yeah yeah sky
looks like he's ready to walk the the
halls of e3
oh cool I could buy rubber bullets from
the hotel for use in mr. alligator I
still don't follow that I always love a
good middle cigarettes
I mean gum aisle sleeping a whole
sleeping bag where do you have to to
sleeping a cleaner oh that might be to
help keep your suit clean oh yeah
antidotes what for poison hopefully
don't ever have to use that could sober
yourself up I'm so excited to see what
this game has to offer
I got a big same I lets up head on out
yeah yeah yeah yeah yes oh now we can do
it
[Music]
compared to non-smokers smokers have a
4.7 times
Patricius of getting lung disease you
know that means it's more likely than
getting asbestos poisoning no one asks
you can be much lower than what you
think it is in fact it's tiny when
compared to heart disease strokes and
pneumonia
we're always surrounded by easy ways to
die you know some people even get
randomly struck by lightning and died
right there on the spot then I reckon
you also know that secondhand smokers
have 1.3 times greater the risk compared
to smokers of course so you won't mind
paying the damages when I dive lung
disease how about writing that in a
contract for me you got a pen boy get
him
oh he actually wrote down I promise to
protect you from all the evil in our
world oh that's stupid
by the way what's her name FBI special
agent Francis York Morgan's York Morgan
I only asked for your name bragging
Patricia contract you should have been
able to figure that out if you're a real
FBI agent like you said come on
sign here right here on the paper just
as I thought Zach this contract paper
it's a song Rouge rapper Oh song Rouge
is here too this must mean that Shawne
Rouge is connected to the LEAs Clarkson
murder the drug right this I think's all
in case that spread across the entire
south it's within our jurisdiction Zack
we'll need to steal the right to
investigate from the local authorities
at once by the way miss what yes
Patricia woods but I gotta write my name
myself or else it won't be a real
signature wait what does that mean okay
it's a forgery if she doesn't sign it
she has to also sign on it if this is
contra have a sheriff or is it under the
jurisdiction Patricia
okay so if their dad the chair enough to
work how should we see this troll from
the sheriff this time does your dad also
like cook out of that van wall he does
sheriffing I have so many questions for
starters they've set up this pattern
that apparently you're all the frame
rate it's okay it's a lot of course that
York apparently just on the regular
steals cases from local law enforcement
I mean
you gotta do what you gotta do look at
that thing I love it it's a general
store and also belongs to the sheriff Oh
a bet depending on what side you
interact with you get different service
that makes sense
hey there so uh you're the fella from
the FBI been hearing so much about
yeah I'm Melvin they call me the sheriff
round here all right
FBI special agent Francis you're Francis
York Morgan but call me York if you can
oh that's not how he says it was me
there we go okay received it Henry the
first half mr. York how's that sound
fine by me I'm sure you figured this out
but our towns a small one yeah folks are
already busy
oh that's growing hurts my eyes now I
reckon you came from the city what was
it DC LA or New York anywho in the city
it's normal not to know who your
neighbor is fella who moves in next to
you could cook up a dozen folks in his
backyard and no one would bat an eye
that's I mean sure die in the city are
they about to like go back and forth
trading movies because it sounds like a
movie voiceover no no see oh gee I'm
just trying to make a little small talk
that's all what what is happening who
around these parts
everyone knows each other's name so lots
of folks get laid when they see an H
wrong J like you and since it's my duty
to protect the town I thought
I'd stop by and say hello Zack it looks
like a party played the happy-go-lucky
type a clear indication of just how
pieces okay so they came here and talked
these Clarkson world information I hope
I love Melvin so much yes he's our new
partner he can't leave us she's just
like I don't know he's my dad but I
don't know the camera angles on
everything nice everything a Dutch angle
my jobs I just stopped my neighbors from
beating the piss out of each other and
listen to old folks complain honestly
this whole murder case is been weighing
me down so imma give you my full
cooperation
okay so keygen honestly as this town's
local law enforcement this murders
really been bumming me out they made
this whole stink about how he stole it
from them this guy's just like yeah man
please please come and help me I'm not
cut out for this have you seen my help
you know explain yourself daddy that's
incredible I don't believe this amazing
did you hear that Zack amazing the body
in a cold storage Hamas's biscuits
this is fan
insanely fantastic hey how did you eat
I'll head on down to the warehouse ahead
of you and make sure we get permission
to search it sounds good the management
company only comes to work how did you
keep certain hours well you'll have to
come during those hours I ain't looking
to create any further disturb but we're
moving past this so fast how did that
happen come on let's roll CLG I'm gonna
walk home daddy
I still got another stop to make Oh seal
GA so sweetie she's a real sharp wound
as you can see so I tried to stay out of
her way well I'll see you at the
warehouse no but for real let's go back
to talk about the fact that he just like
touched his head and was like ah the
dead body in the warehouse and everyone
bought into it did I like blank blank
out and miss something I know I have no
idea what happened in that entire
conversation they were talking about
something completely different than all
of a sudden York literally just goes off
ya sack you're right love it
tie me up bridges skateboard framerate
what's the skateboard buttons let's find
out
okay so we have between now and 5 5
o'clock to go to the warehouse so let's
go to the docks go to the diner cuz I
feel like that where there you go oh
hello it's the wife it's the Y button I
love the skateboard music already
we didn't even need scape for but I'd
love is just open hands while he's doing
it - you ain't secretly cutting kids up
and sticking them into jars while you
work as an FBI agent on the surface are
you or use the kid for connections to
sell kids child trafficking
organizations I've arrested people
who've done both but I've never engaged
in either of those activities myself of
course I would never things in order to
learn more about the psychology of the
criminals I deal with it was just a joke
why are you getting all serious don't
tell me why did you ask him that
or else I'll get scared of you for real
hey John can I come with you you signed
a copy of your own skateboard and
besides I'm kind of worried about my
daddy do whatever you like this is
America land of the free but I have one
condition what condition don't ask me
about Zach it's a private matter
Zach it feels like she's carrying
something with her kind of reminds me of
you back when we first met I can't leave
her alone like this you feel the same
way don't you
[Music]
okay
okay main quad in question cyclists yeah
that's the same thing that's the same
that's the same that's oh my gosh look
at all these things we can do okay well
it tells us the direction this m12 is
the one we want to go to yeah over there
okay cool Maps you can set custom
waypoint that's good
here's a question how far out can you
zoom you can ask you the whole app you
really love to see it at you you you
genuinely love to see it but yeah we're
people who've played Deadly Premonition
one will understand our pain it's true
yeah well let's head out on the road and
over to the Diane let's let's go to the
diamond yeah dog bend this frame rate
yeah I'm uh I think I'm seeing
wait did he just quit conversations
I wish you'd call me something normal
Patricia
now that it's gotten
how about Zack and I call you
do whatever you like
the whistles which she just stopped so
she Sprint's alongside us while we were
riding on the skateboard maybe oh oh my
god this framerate
paddy is something wrong I got something
to say we're not first met you in the
hotel parking lot
you mentioned snow Rouge right if you
want to find it
maybe you should track down the whole 30
seconds ago professor are cool professor
are owns the jazz bar on the other side
of the Bayou a jazz bar how do you know
that because like jazz huh
do you like jazz
[Music]
Alexis owls nest okay that's what's at
that stuff
oh there are other places I think so
so howls nest is over there on the map I
see that okay let's head inside this
diner yeah let's hit up you know diners
always the spots be
okay this is kind of nice yeah oh wow
yeah it has a single bowling lane weird
you love to see it
[Music]
inspects sometimes the customs away huh
can we can we get sunburned Oh baby
maybe this place is fascinating bowling
and Cajun food who would have thought it
reminds me of an old Godzilla films he's
breathing real heavily ten maidens sack
let's topple their hourglass figures and
complete this Oracle once and for all
oh my lord
I don't believe I've eaten you around
here before sorry honey but you can't
smoke in here
whoa since you're with Patricia I'm
guessing your son friend of Melvin's
he's agent York from the FBI Comey York
is Alexis her imposters restaurant I'm
helping out agent York and his
investigation we sent a contract oh my
lord well ain't that something
oh I do love that you've got lime FBI
specialist there we go surfing
please call me York everyone's calling
that we got like been talking about you
it's real good okay okay
I want two wafers instead don't put too
many rice krispies on it oh but don't
scrimp on the chocolate Fira bother oh
my lord
and what'll it be for you honey coffee
Alexis are these photos of the town oh
you like my pitches hobbies collecting
snapshots of what a town used to be like
so whenever someone gives me an old
picture I just put it up here on display
our world these days feels a bit cold to
me you know just thought it'd be nice to
help folks remember what it was like in
the good old days
Zack did you hear that the good old days
even in a remote town that's already far
behind the times there are still people
who yearn for the past she told me what
was going on you know what Lise you
don't need to try and hide it from me
honey last time she came here she told
me all about it some odd fella was
following her around huh
stalking I like what what kind of fellow
wait she said he had a really tall
shadow huh
how tall as tall as an oak tree how did
we get to did that ring any bells for
you oh hold on wait what is going on
just about everyone in this here town
but I ain't never seen a man who stands
that tall maybe it really was an oak
tree and she just mistook it for someone
sometimes the silhouettes of them trees
with lots of Spanish moss hanging down
make me feel a little funny to no one I
know Alexis leaf said the shadow was
following her sure Luke I'm worried she
must have been stalked by a tree I've
given up I have no idea what's happening
right now it felt like a crowd of people
was staring at me yes exactly what if
she certainly wouldn't have talked about
being followed by someone Thank You
patty
what
Zach this data is all very intriguing
but it isn't the answer we're looking
for
we came to knock down the ten maidens
remember sure you've got to get a strike
Oh
hold on she's the best character in the
game this is why I never tire of small
town investigations same goes for you
right
please go bowl with that that lovely old
woman oh you know it all please
[Music]
this isn't bullying excuse me ma'am Oh
howdy stranger you're telling me you
came out here from the city didn't you I
can always spot you city folk from a
mile away
yeah I'm FBI Special Agent Francis York
Morgan would you mind calling me York
ma'am ah so you are from the FBI so how
much you want to bet there are as many
characters you talk to in this game as
there are letters in the alphabet and
each highlighted letter is never oh my
god in their names one even predicted
when I bowled my first perfect game Oh
No Oh could you stand a bit closer to me
if you move any further that way you'll
cast a shadow over the lane
sure a tall man casting a big shadow
[Music]
first time in 12 years I was mortified
I'm going to make you have a basket of
gems yeah some nice little sparkling
gemstones back there some real
good-lookin rocks some routines lead to
good things while others only lead to
the bad you mustn't ever cast action is
that understood
it's her routine Zak understand just
like us and coffee incidentally ma'am
would you mind letting me use this Lane
- I'm investigating the lease Clarkson
murder case and therefore I need to bowl
a perfect ten
excuse me I'm in the middle of a murder
investigation I have to pull some sick
frames real quick well like you don't
own it but it's there's only one lane
that makes no sense
oh there's teeth oh yeah mama Zack it
looks like negotiations have failed now
I'm afraid we have no choice but to
force her to let us use her bowling lane
don't do it York I won't do anything
illegal what why did the he like froze
okay I did the objective literally say
don't do something illegal
pull up your objectives real quick some
of those illegal okay you're gonna push
her down the lake
excuse me mrs. carpenter can't you see
I'm already in my bowling stance what
are you blind clearly
never bull much no I was asking you
Ben's do you ever bull much uh
not much anymore so yeah I got I got
caught up in her asking about splits uh
but yeah used to do it a fair amount
wasn't spectacularly good or anything
but I enjoyed it
mm-hmm it should've been great at
bowling but I like the atmosphere
bowling alleys yeah there's something
nice about though just kind of the
sounds yeah the sights there's an arcade
sometimes attached to them which is our
taste of times you get some really
greasy terrible food yeah yeah kids
having a birthday party over in the
corner
oh no oh okay I hope she doesn't die
never fails
just like FK in the coffee Zach our new
friend appears to be a very
superstitious lady we should try and
utilize this trait of hers in order to
gain access to the lane for a bit that
was an amazing shot mrs. carpenter in
fact it may have been the most amazing
shot I've ever seen you are beautiful
and I love you you bowl like the best
person I've ever seen bowl find all
those neat little items the ones you
used to help you bow that split just now
whoa you got a keen eye there mr.
special agent taking a liking to my
collection have you oh yes a great
liking I'm confiscating it they're all
mine power stones from air zuly free
power stone their Zhu Li Freda yes it's
a mystical establishment run by the
mirror the mirror if you're interested I
can mark it on your map for you that's
my that for me
York's is good at asking questions
Zhu Li Freda is something there must be
a treasure trove of dubious trinkets on
sale there we may even be able to find
something capable of changing her mind
it really feels like we're in the deep
south now doesn't it does it i we're
gonna diner with a single boy ally all
right I guess we're on our way to go
pick up some cool trinkets dude let's do
it man yeah I'm calling this we need to
bowl it's the most important thing his
it's just barreling forward with his
arms out always gets me yes I did then
why are you leaving you gave up on
trying to convince mrs. carpenter to let
you play no patty neither Zack nor I
have given up on anything we're just
going to stop by our Zhu lis Frieda
or Zhu Li Frieda what do you want with
that place what do you know about it
patty it's a dumb store that sells
stupid voodoo charms and even stupider
souvenirs
no one who actually lives here would
ever be caught dead there daddy even
told me to steer clear of it and why is
that cause they sell guns
you mean Erzulie freedom oh hello
it's a voodoo gun shop you patty you
just helped me make up my mind we're
going to use the power of Voodoo to help
us steal the right to use that leg
why is this plotline Oh God
I'm all for it is that is that the right
we're going the right way I think so yes
14 okay
oh look at the speed lines now we're
really cruising but how do you do tricks
that's what we need it's a great
question much unlocks I love the
skateboard song so much it's real good a
voodoo shop it's a voodoo shop shop to
me of course it does Patti you're much
too young to understand the true value
of such a place
[Music]
I'm really curious how York is going to
further expand on the true value of such
a place I need to be I need to be taken
there I need to understand what your
thought process is okay that was in your
room before I was in my room before hmm
it's just a bunch of charms dope
those aren't kids things we would put
Trisha okay
she just why didn't she say guns she
just like it stops yeah
also guns are I can have a gun no sense
you agree right agent York you'll let me
buy a gun right York look just kill to
write all the mysticism of the deep
south gathered up into one quaint little
shop this is a hundred times more
exciting than the FBI evidence vault
holding fast okay yes so much to study
so much to learn
[Music]
okay yeah there are the guns in there
are the trinkets it's just all here yeah
[Music]
the mirror
[Music]
say I really hope their whole gave me
cuz let me just do what you do without
Auto seeker and I see the object of that
desire does this be what thou seekest is
that the gun that shoots the rubber
bullets and the weed way please tell me
that he is alligators a gun and only now
if fortune shall not bless me with
another chance purchase this and know
that I wish --is shall be granted
that's crazy it even I can tell you're
getting cheated agent York at a high
price Susan can be true I've been stable
for quite a while so I can tell that
figurine is connected to our future my
prize that's true
what Sadie damn man does let's buy it
yeah load it up wash this alligator
figure sure 30 bucks is best eel I'll
buy it
wow what a man of refined taste darn t I
am loath to part with it but would be a
fool's errand to keep it from such a
keen eyed soul what's wrong with you no
normal person would ever buy a piece of
junk like that not even at a garage sale
marvelous isn't it Zack what are the
treasure mm-hmm can't wait to use it I
can't wait to use it use it where how
isn't it obvious patty I'm going to put
it in front of mrs. carpenter's house
what front of her house mmm yes
I'm sure this figurine will stop her
right in her tracks
and that'll give us a chance to finally
topple the ten maidens are you serious
of course I am and so is Zach aren't you
I'm seriously wondering if I should quit
helping you out with this it seems like
he talks a lot more about Zach in the
open than me yeah well we're like other
characters acknowledge it more in this
one yeah it's very weird okay we've
bought the thing see what else is going
on sale in here yeah so looks like a
late night adventure yeah I don't think
we can do that right now tell me about
your charm necklaces dolls incense too
close means what boost your performance
in mini games your charms okay all right
this is this a new thing create a charm
stamina paralysis poison boosts
concentration life stamina a giant doll
clown doll priest all there are a lot of
dolls here we don't have any of the
materials for any of these dude I want
plus three to my beard oh hey yeah I'm
buying that one Oh can't we wait we dyed
the material yeah
no no well now we know what we need to
get the return is imminent
thou hath discover the very and then we
can enhance the the beard talisman charm
okay guess I can't look
story whoa that was close
oh wait a minute well look at you
all standing there like you're expecting
me to apologize your fault for not
paying attention hello got a moment
can't say I do I'm in a hurry here
I won't take up too much of your time
I'd just like to ask you a few questions
I said I'm in a hurry picker would Oh
Patti what was that that was Bella goth
from the original Sims game what is she
doing here York Zack we found ourselves
at Clark's oh she's not here Holly here
one of the key persons in this case just
came out of the woodwork to meet us now
things are really getting interesting
isn't that right Zack all right let's
let's see what we can what we can do
here so that I have to do at night yeah
what's the oh that's just a side quest
for making a charm though we'll get to
that eventually
yeah so it looks like we might have to
just go to the cold storage unless we
like cruise around town seems like it
can I tie skate through the park I hope
so
oh my man he's got those powerful thighs
to push through that grass on the
skateboard he's doing it that's the day
[Music]
I'm so happy oh my god that's it it's
sealed it's everything I needed just
excellent
so you think
it's talking
is the skeletal gentlemen for
or does he merely exist outside the wait
hold on the whistles it sounds like it
like an alternate instrumentation of
life is beautiful a little bit I can't
tell I might be losing my mind
[Music]
oh I guess we're done having that
conversation you've got to go fast to
have conversations oh [ __ ]
there we go
don't run that poor woman over nope
so hello I need to go that way ah my
favorite the 4x4 oh there's a cemetery
yeah the coal storage is over here so
we'll probably just probably stop right
over here all right and call it call it
a bit sounds like a plan to me oh but
wait hold on wait what is [ __ ] hold on
hold on hold on what the what is why
hold on that's is it what I think it is
it does look like a little like packages
they look like
delivery drones do you you don't have a
gun or anything right no I don't think I
do here let me pull up inventory here we
go
and add bullets but I don't have mr.
alligator dang no all right that's fair
you're just teasing us with the cool
things flying in the sky look you're
like tiny will UFO is this whatever
happened oh we got franching bits oh
because it's probably main story so like
this has got a real kind of like a 9 9 9
9 kind of presentation going on got we
got webs story webs
some somnium files nonsense
absolutely all right well I think we're
gonna call it here then before we head
into that cold storage just leave
everyone else out in the cold you have
to guess where York ends up next I think
you may have stumbled into the cutscenes
oh no never mind out right there look at
car though I gotta run to the save first
oh yeah that's right yeah oh I forgot
about that I'm coming for your own
aggressive run I love it all right I
think this we're gonna call it here you
know if you guys have made it this far
we're still enjoying it please let us
know and maybe we'll keep playing more
of this for you guys if that's something
you're interested in yeah please please
let us know because I want to keep doing
this alright guys see you next time
[Music]